Cómo podemos tomar estas declaraciones
del presidente Putin son confiables
Muchas gracias por la invitación yo creo
que lo que dice Vladimir Putin indica
que hay un cansancio enorme en Rusia de
la guerra y básicamente en ninguno de
los objetivos de Rusia o por lo menos
los objetivos que fueron anunciados por
Vladimir Putin al inicio de la invasión
de Ucrania en febrero de este año no son
cumplidos y lo que está buscando
Vladimir Putin Aparentemente es una
salida de esta situación que cada vez se
presenta mayores problemas por él por
los costos de la guerra por el cansancio
de los rusos y básicamente porque yo
creo que pronto ya las sanciones e
impuestos sobre Rusia va a tener un
impacto a un mayor en comparación lo que
está pasando ahora Cómo podemos
interpretar lo que él llama como
soluciones aceptables A qué se refiere
el presidente ruso
bueno sabemos que Vladimir Putin cambia
lo que dice con frecuencia no está
acostumbrado que alguien cuestiona lo
que él está diciendo y en este momento
yo creo que no tenemos una respuesta
Clara cuál pueden ser estos condiciones
Rusia ha perdido el terreno en Ucrania a
pesar que fue declarada
Rusia declaró estos territorios como
parte de su territorio nuevamente pero
básicamente yo creo que debemos esperar
que van a aparecer mayores detalles por
ahora no está muy claro Cuáles van a ser
estas condiciones Bueno yo le preguntaba
si las palabras de Putin pueden ser
confiables del lado ucraniano hay
suficiente confianza para creer en este
mensaje
no yo creo que Ucrania no cree en nada
lo que está diciendo Putin está
preparándose para lo peor lo que puede
venir luego con la acumulación de la
fuerza sobre todo el ejército está
creciendo en Rusia hay planes para
aumentar casi 60 por ciento la cantidad
de los efectivos en el ejército y
Ucrania necesito más que nunca el apoyo
que todavía está obteniendo desde el
occidente desde algunos otros países
pero creo que los ucranianos va a
esperar algo un poco más que simplemente
las palabras de Vladimir bueno y
justamente estas palabras podrían
considerarse una forma de calmar a la
comunidad internacional
No tampoco yo creo que en este momento
hay algo de confianza porque básicamente
Vladimir antes de iniciar la guerra en
febrero de este año también estaba
diciendo que lo que hace Rusia son
maniobras y resulta que sí Estaba
preparando para la guerra yo creo que no
hay confianza las palabras de Vladimir
Putin las acciones y esto nos toca
esperar para ver cuál va a ser si van a
ver los cambios